[Applause]
[Music]
Nicaragua used to be considered the
safest country in South America and at
the same time the second poorest but now
it seems like things are changing
you see Nicaragua is a country full of
contradictions its President Daniel
Ortega likes to brag about his deep
Marxist Leninist roots and yet he
defines himself as a Catholic and has
even banned abortion in the country
nonetheless find that facade of moral
rectitude there's a man facing an open
trial for abusing his stepdaughter
despite this Daniel Teague is known as a
big-time family man in fact you know you
the Nicaraguan vice president is well
that would be his wife
Rosario Marie Jo yeah I know you're
thinking mr. Ortega probably not the
kind of guy you want to have as a
president right well before you start
judging him too harshly here's the other
side of that coin he's been in power
since 2007 with a popular support rating
higher than 60% and even we have to
admit that when it comes to Foreign
Relations he's a genius Nicaragua is one
of the few countries that has ties with
Iran Russia Venezuela and at the same
time the United States of America yes
you heard that right many of his
comrades in the Sandinista front his
political party accuse him of selling
his soul to capitalism and they're not
entirely wrong yeah although Nicaragua
is a poor country it's also one of the
most stable economies in the region with
an average GDP growth rate of 4.6%
the population living below the poverty
line is getting smaller and smaller year
after year
don't believe me well just look at the
immigration statistics and you'll see an
exodus of Guatemalans and Mexicans
moving to the USA but Nicaraguan
citizens seem to be comfortable staying
in their home country apparently they're
satisfied with the political situation
or at least there used to be the final
straw came with pension reform the
government has reduced the amount of
money that retired people get and at the
same time has increased what workers
have to pay into the system as you can
imagine nobody like this policy
neither the businessman nor the workers
this is how the biggest demonstration
against Daniel Ortega's regimes started
they've tried to repress these protests
with police brutality and massive
imprisonments many people have already
lost their lives even the government has
sent their own sympathizers to confront
the protesters but so far none of these
measures have stopped the demonstrations
so now the question becomes why is all
of this happening now when Nicaragua has
no economic crisis whatsoever are we
witnessing the end of Daniel Tiger's
rule are we about to see the end of the
sand and Easter Nicaragua well today we
are going to answer all of these
questions but before we do let's take a
look back at the history Sandinista yeah
I know the title of this section is
going to ring a bell for many of you if
you were alive during the 1980s you
might have heard of this and an Easter
album from the British punk band The
Clash the truth is during the 80s
Nicaragua became a symbol of the
struggle against American imperialism
[Music]
back then the Sandinista fronted made
its way to power after decades of a far
right-wing dictatorship if I tell you
that the Sandinista Front defines itself
as a Marxist Leninist anti-american
political party you won't be surprised
but here's the funny part they combine
all of that ideology with religion have
you ever heard of liberation theology
but it was a movement within the
Catholic Church especially among
latin-american Roman Catholics and its
followers we're diehard supporters of
these sandanista comrades - I hear there
is some message genuine and true you see
on the screen now that is Daniel Ortega
back then he was already the leader of
the Sandinista front and the presidents
of Nicaragua as you can imagine in the
middle of the Cold War America wasn't
about to let this country fall under
communist rule without a fight
that's why then American President
Ronald Reagan organized one of the most
controversial decisions in American
history for one he sold his weapons to
the ayatollahs in Iran who were fighting
Saddam Hussein's Iraq of course this was
a top secret deal because Iran was
officially an enemy of the United States
after that he took all the money from
the sales to finance the so-called
contra in Nicaragua the Contras were a
far right-wing terrorist group that
fought against the governments of Daniel
Ortega I'm speaking of Nicaragua a
Soviet Air I on the American mainland
only two hours flying time from our own
borders for our own security the United
States must deny the Soviet Union of
in North America as you can imagine when
this story got leaks the media went
pretty crazy and so did the world of
music that's why we have so many songs
and records from those times from The
Clash to Kris Kristofferson
what did Daniel Ortega do while he was
in power well in a way you could say
that he's set a precedent for Nicolas
Maduro as Venezuela
in short the sandanista government
nationalized all of the companies that
were in the hands of the local oligarchs
and how did they pay for all of this
well they did that by getting more and
more loans from the Soviet Union and of
course printing money like there was no
tomorrow and what was the outcome of all
of this well in the year 1986 after
little more than five years under
Ortega's rule Nicaragua was suffering
from one of the worst cases of
hyperinflation of all time in the
bitterest days of the conflict between
the country's former Sandinista leaders
and American backed rebels all
Nicaraguan shared one crucial piece of
common ground their reliance on the
American dollar just imagine that the
value of the local currency V Cordoba
would value every 15 days this means
that if you bought it there one day and
paid say 10 Cordova's you'd come back
four months later and the same there
would be over 3,000 now we've told you
many times Iran is your politic that the
worst thing that can happen to a country
is hyperinflation this is why despite
the fact that Daniel Ortega have so much
support the citizens showed him that
backs this is why in the year 1990
Nicaragua had a new currency the golden
Cordoba at a different government this
time a conservative one during the 90s
Daniel Ortega was the leader of the
opposition party meanwhile the country
was getting rid of that hyperinflation
and it was coming back to the situation
of stable poverty
you know Nicaraguans kept being poor but
at least they didn't have big surprises
the purchasing power wouldn't diminish
because there's not so much inflation
and there were no more Wars or terrorist
attacks
and this is how we get to the year 2006
the year when Nicaragua hell's new
elections and let's have a look at what
happened
[Music]
from Marxists - or take us in 2006
Ortega returned to the government's but
this time he was a different version of
himself of course he was still a member
of the sandanista front but so many
years as the opposition helps reshape
his ideas Daniel Ortega no longer
supports Marxist Leninist and is now a
supporter of Ortega Z that is the
problem testimonial from asan bestow
supporter of course this brand-new
version of Daniel Ortega still sticks to
the same old socialist rhetoric his
government guarantees universal access
to health care and education in fact
both illiteracy rates and average life
expectancy have increased in the country
but that rush for nationalization has
given way to more moderate discourse
white-collar workers blue-collar workers
farmers producers entrepreneurs small
businessmen and big businessmen all the
economic and social powers of the
country let's work together
wait a minute here because there's even
more 30 years ago Nicaragua was the guy
that the u.s. loved to hate but now
they've signed a free trade with America
the so called captain man's they
celebrate with counter narco operations
bear in mind that the American
agriculture market is over protected but
chocolate coffee and bananas from
Nicaragua and the exception to that rule
they find it way easier to get into
those American market
[Music]
and this still is not the end of our
story
did you remember about special economic
zones I've told you about them in a
video before basically they're an area
inside of a developing country with
lower taxes and more business-friendly
rules
well Nicaragua has got one the images
you're beginning to see on the screen
now they belong to an ad made by the
government to attract foreign investors
if someone was thinking of investing in
that broad way I would encourage them to
come down and and I think they'll find
the same advantages that we found not
was close to the US strong bilingual
population availability of highly
educated workforce surprisingly assumes
this insult a who came to power
Nicaragua has been flooded with new call
centers from international companies
she played there special taxes and most
importantly of all the opportunity to do
business in the only country with no
street violence or gorillas whatsoever
so now you might be wondering what
happened to Daniel Ortega did he have an
epiphany Wow he just learns that when a
country does well under your rule it's
easier to stay in power this is why an
election after election Ortega gets more
than 60 percent of the vote of course
these elections are rigs but only a fool
would say that Ortega has no popular
support in fact there's also another
reason for this ideological change you
see if the economy of your country is
doing alright since you control every
facet over your country your personal
finances are going to be pretty darn
great the President Daniel Ortega has
put his wife and sons in important
government positions while his family
has gotten a rich thanks to Venezuelan
oil meanwhile his government has
invested a good share of that money in
avoiding political rivalries virtually
every media station in Nicaragua is
owned by governments or some businessman
that's connected to Daniel Ortega and by
the way there's a new social media law
which started to be discussed in March
of 2018 and this would allow the ruling
class to censor and chase political
activists nonetheless protests have
started for a totally different reason
that's some look at that
[Music]
why do they protest in Nicaragua common
wisdom says that revolutions happen when
a country is in a big crisis right well
that's actually a big mistake
in fact revolutions happen when a
country was going through dire straits
that is now starting to grow and why is
this well basically if nobody around you
is driving a Cadillac then there are no
Cadillacs to be jealous about you can
probably see where I'm going with this
all of a sudden Nicaraguans are
witnessing the advent of a brand new
elite the Friends of Daniel Ortega
[Music]
yes it is true the whole country is
growing but some are growing faster than
others and only the most naive believed
that this new aristocracy got rich
entirely on their own merit this is what
we call the populist moment a window of
opportunity where the government can
change this is like filling a room with
gas you just need a flick of a lighter
and boom everything explodes
[Music]
controversial inss law has already
passed in summary the government has
decided to lower pensions while
increasing contributions businessman
workers and students have taken to the
streets like that spent years waiting
for the opportunity thousands of people
are protesting and the government the
government doesn't know how to react
this is why they have forced all the
Nicaraguan TV stations to stop
broadcasting the demonstrations despite
all of this protests being organized all
over the country
not only in the capital but even in its
smallest villagers in fact we know about
this because we've received thousands of
messages from protesters as you probably
know visual politics also got a
spanish-language version and those who
watch that channel from Nicaragua have
sent hundreds of videos from
universities
[Music]
in these videos you can see that
students they've been sitting there for
days people bring them food and water
but then a policeman will come and take
it away and we have plenty of images of
police brutality they were not going to
show here but trust us when we say that
the Nicaraguan police are doing
everything they can to repress these
protests it's big time clash of forces
in what you used to be the most peaceful
country in South America
[Music]
and now the question you might ask is is
this the end of Daniel Ortega's rule and
as we always say here official politic
you can never make accurate predictions
when it comes to politics and economics
having a lot of protesters doesn't
really mean anything in fact we still
don't know if all these political
activists serve a common cause or a
common leader according to the messages
we get there are some liberal factions
as well as some diehard sent and Easter
people who feel betrayed by mr. Ortegas
ideological shift as you can imagine
things like special economic zones not
very Marxist Leninist in other words so
far there isn't much organization and
there's no leader that can capitalize on
all this popular unrest without this it
is hard to offer a real alternative to
the official power
but that's our opinion here official
politic now we'd like to know yours what
do you think is going to happen do you
really think Daniel Ortega will have to
step down from power or will we see many
more years of sand anism
well please leave your answer in the
comment section below and please don't
forget to visit our friends from the
ring consider media podcast they
provided the vocals in this video that
were not mine and of course remember
that we published brand new videos every
Monday and Thursday so be sure to hit
that subscribe button so you won't miss
any posts and as always see you next
time and if you want to learn more about
politics and here even more of my lovely
voice you can join us at reconsider
media we have a podcast at reconsider
mediacom slash podcast see you there
[Music]